this is the ecta
a 300 000 ton tanker vessel built in
1995 to carry oil around the world
it was one of the largest of its kind
when it first set sail
the ecta sailed under several different
names and flags throughout its 22 years
of service
and in 2017 this massive vessel set out
on its final voyage
to one of the largest ship breaking
yards in the world
around 90 of the world's goods are
transported by
sea and there are nearly 100 000
large-scale commercial vessels sailing
the world's oceans
from oil tankers and cargo ships to
fishing vessels and car carriers once a
ship reaches the end of its operational
life
it can be sent to a ship breaking yard
to be broken down and recycled
we try and track every vessel that ends
up
at a breaking yard and what we've seen
is that approximately 90 percent of the
tonnage
ends up on only three beaches in south
asia so one in
india one in bangladesh and one in
pakistan
the acta ended up here in chittagong a
port city on the southeastern coast of
bangladesh
home to one of the world's three largest
ship breaking yards
approximately six to seven hundred
vessels
are sold to the beaching guys annually
and i usually sell them
via scrap dealers that are known as cash
buyers
that purchase the vessel's cash from the
ship owner
often change the flag of the ship change
a crew of the ship
change the registration of the ship and
bring the vessels
to one of the three beaches in south
asia
these are 12 kilometer long beach
stretches with a huge tidal range
and the vessels ramped up during high
tide and broken down
during low tide the larger commercial
vessels will end up
at these beaching hours and you'll have
tankers cruise ships
military vessels you'll even have
floating platforms
and they contain large amounts of steel
which is good to recycle
so they are usually sold and then taken
apart
for this steel to be used in
construction work
or in smelting to create new
new pieces of iron
[Music]
ship breaking is a largely sustainable
industry but without the proper
equipment or enforcement of regulations
the industry can have negative effects
on both the workers and the surrounding
environment
ships can contain a number of hazardous
materials such as waste oils heavy
metals and even asbestos
the safest way to recycle a ship is in a
dry dock where the hazardous materials
can be easily contained
but this method is expensive and there
are very few dry docks equipped for ship
breaking
another method of recycling which is
popular in turkey and other countries
is the landing or slipway breaking
method where ships are partially landed
on shore
and broken up from the top down in this
method the hull of the ship itself
prevents toxic materials from entering
the environment
the most common method of ship breaking
though is beaching
it's the preferred method in india
bangladesh and pakistan
and experts say beaching is where they
see the greatest environmental and human
[Music]
impact
the workers in all three countries there
are internal migrant workers that come
from
northern regions poorer regions where
there is a lack of employment
and they are often contracted on a daily
basis
they work in different facilities they
will
lack training they will need to purchase
their own protective equipment in some
yards and not have the money to do that
and in bangladesh we've seen that
approximately 13
of the workforce are underage so
under 18 teenagers and this is
illegal according to also bangladesh
national law because it's considered a
heavy and hazardous industry
where under 18 should not be working
but these have been employed and often
during night shifts
which is even riskier than than working
during the day
to avoid labor inspectors it would take
everything from four to six months maybe
longer
to to take the vessel apart there are
many
causes of accidents at the yard
the last six months we've been able to
document
at least 11 workers that have lost their
lives at the beaching yards
but we believe that these numbers do not
reflect
the entire picture as the fatalities are
seldom recorded or made
available publicly the information about
accidents
and it doesn't count of course the
numerous workers that become sick
and die of of cancer years after having
worked at the arts
[Music]
south asia isn't the only region of the
world where ships are recycled
the european union keeps a list of ship
recycling facilities that it's
determined to meet high safety and
environmental standards
so when when the ship arrives in the
yard the first thing we do is the
pre-cleaning
so that's removal of all hazardous
materials
in um all the accommodation
wood paneling furniture just name it
after that we got a steel hull before
that we do all the
the asbestos removal once the asbestos
is removed then you start cutting up on
the superstructure
removing of engine rooms all the engines
all all yours etc
the remaining hull is pulled on a
slipway and this is caught up in in
smaller pieces with hydraulic pincers
and and mobile cranes at the bottom of
the slipway you've got a gully
so would there be anything left in
inside the hull
it's catch up in the gully and then
treat it further downwards in in the
water treatment system
when you start cutting down a ship
you're always bound to be at two three
four meters high
so every opening we got fences all
around
all the guys have got falling gear with
the lifelines and all that sort of thing
so
today all the arts are really anxious to
get to get more vessels in
more than 20 cruise vessels i went for
recycling
the last six months and not just one
single vessel ended up in europe
[Music]
so with a number of cleaner safer ship
breaking yards available
why don't ship owners send their vessels
to europe vessels are sold
per per ton and in south asia right now
a ship owner can earn up to 400
per ton whilst in a more sustainable
facility in the u.s so in in europe
and the recycling yard would be able to
pay 100 to 150 dollars per ton
europe is the biggest net exporter of
scrap steel
south asia is a big net importer of
is turkey so the countries that recycles
it do not recycle them because it's
a kind of an attractive industry it is
just that they need
for for the steel primarily then they
make
great use of all second-hand machinery
and all kinds of materials in europe
you wouldn't use a secondhand pump
that's been on a ship for 20 years
in india they do and they take the
generators and run
villages the electricity for villages to
recycle ships in europe doesn't make
at all economic sense and the yards that
exist in europe
take small ships and take ships that are
kind of
need to be recycled and cannot travel a
long distance
[Music]
despite the poor working conditions in
some of the yards of south asia
the region has seen some improvement in
addition
international legislation such as the
hong kong convention for the safe and
environmentally sound recycling of ships
which was adopted in 2009 but has not
yet entered into force
has the potential to dramatically
improve standards in yards around the
world
the convention is setting an
international set of regulations
that govern what materials are allowed
on the ship
the convention requires that recycling
yards follow certain norms
and has requirements for safety
environmental protection
training of workers imaginary response
the major delay is because
countries who have significant recycling
industries
have to be sure the ideas that are
located in their country are capable of
following the requirements
countries where most of the ships are
registered they can
have very little to worry because
requirements on shipowners
are quite reasonable to follow and
reasonable to police so at the moment
the the convention would enter in the
force if either china or bangladesh
ratifies the convention
[Music]
[Applause]
when i started working i honestly did
not think
that it would be necessary to still work
on this issue
15 years on but the shipping industry
has proven to be
extremely conservative and very close to
its
money so they are not willing to give up
the
extra profit they're currently earning
on exploiting
workers and the environment in south
asia
international waste law forbids the
exports of hazardous
waste from developed to developing
countries
and what we're seeing with the
ship-breaking years is a massive
disrespect of international law
more companies are adopting sustainable
policies
by seeing enforcement authorities
bringing criminal charges against
ship owners that are attempting to
circumvent
or have circumvented the legislation
and because there is an increased focus
on circular
economy and green deals so i do
believe that there is a positive future
for
sustainable recycling at proper
facilities
you